because Matt Damon's ponytail is ended
up with its own Twitter account I do
know that it sounds weird okay but also
people you know people really
appreciated that ponytail on Twitter I
don't know if you found some of the
tweets that people so mmm Matt Damon
with a man bun sad lady boner
they they get worse you think you were
basically understanding of the world
then you see Matt Damon's ponytail and
nothing makes sense this one this one's
quite extreme
Matt Damon it's a ponytail never go to
the top table I think my ovaries might
explode so never put it in a time
don't do that who knows what this last
one means Matt Damon I will use your
ponytail to steer while you dine upon my
lady sandwich
[Applause]
I mean you don't have to go far on the
interweb to find quite extreme reactions
to that scene with your shirt on here's
what somebody tell Michael B Jordan that
my ovaries already Michael see George
[Music]
[Applause]
there's more there's a lot more is
another one this Michael B Jordan make
anyone else want to rip their lungs out
[Laughter]
even erotic reaction so created so sexy
I'm gonna eat my lung
I would sell three toes and one kidney
to be in the same room have you guys do
you follow him on Twitter no you should
James's tweets can we all take a moment
to remember just how terrible James
Blunt was no need I have a new album
coming soon
satyrs bloggers at Twitter what would he
even tweet about boning your mom
guess what a James Blunt a Solapur
caliber table would have died they said
Hitler I'm guessing this is not little
bit a James what never hurt anybody
depends where I put it this tyranny to
listen to James but when I'm
menstruating useful feedback I'll pass
this on to my marketing team James
Blunt's face fully aggravates me then
sit on something else
[Applause]
how do you planned the loose strand no
it kind of just fell that way yeah I
mean it looks it looks lovely
but if Twittersphere meltdown this hair
here's just a selection of some of the
tweets that say in single strand of hair
it's prettier than my entire
we haven't seen the person it could be
true it's another one Saenz hair is the
reason I love this stay in there tonight
is why I still
this this is devious is it someone was
just so moved all the cheap was this
[Applause]
died his shoulder
this is sweet right so the fans because
the fans who go to do it
they then of course want to blog about
it because they've had this amazing
experience when they've long about its
borderline confusing on it whether they
had a good time or not so here are some
of the blog things so we were asked to
go to the living room sit down not too
how much I was sweating during that
moment I was like the [ __ ] is gonna
happen keep up then all of a sudden she
just pops up out of nowhere she appeared
out of thin air like David Copperfield
so she said she we playing her album for
us let me tell you the noise think about
of my mouth who was not human did you
almost old mama swift to call me an
ambulance because I was going to make so
much cuz they always talk about dying
rest in peace me r.i.p me died dead we
did a little break as she was pasta
ground rice krispie treats and cookies
and I've spoken to her mom Friddle and
then I walked back in and she was like
hey babe thanks for coming do you want
to treat why was that guy would what I
think
[Applause]
this is brilliant mid sense that she
stopped talking appointed to Amanda it
said Amanda I'm so glad to hear Amanda
died
[Applause]
perfectly finally guys just wait for the
one she did with Imogen Heap
cuz damn that one slayed everyone to
heaven her back while listening to the
song I literally had to plan
is is Chris Pine you do the accent you
get the costumes like to look right
you're in those grueling you know
conditions in Scotland filming for
months and then you premiere the film in
Toronto and that's not what got
attention oh dear what happened yeah
what happened well I have sorry there's
a scene in the film where I am I I bear
the and yeah that seemed well yeah full
monty the front or the back you know if
you don't like one you can talk the
other it's all different strokes for
different cases so International Film
Festival you know we can party and these
are the tweets or the tweets mornings
members Chris mind full-frontal a la
king that's pretty much where a review
this is a PSA that are looking for
because max booty an appetizer of the
frames featuring is soaking wet full
frontal nudity thankfully Netflix has a
pause
[Laughter]
better one that I think is vanity here
like oh yeah there there five there F
and brutal yeah we've this one there's
one more in here day one observed it
down until I've been seriously impressed
by the performances of newcomers like
crisp lines pubes and crisp lines penis
[Music]
you